today i am going to
be giving you a full run through of the
singapore malaysia water conflict this
is something i knew nothing about before
the class but i've really enjoyed
learning more about during this like
process and applying things we've
learned um in the class this semester so
please um ask questions if things are
not clear um i can't promise i have an
answer but i'm excited to share what
i've learned
um
okay so these are the things i'm going
to run through today
basically give you an overview of the
case then dive into the water resources
for both areas and the key stakeholders
as well as a brief overview of the
agreements and then try to spend the
bulk of the presentation talking about
the water diplomacy framework and how i
see room for improvement
so this is a map of the region just in
case you're not familiar with this part
of southeast asia so malaysia is much
larger than singapore and for this case
we're only considering peninsular
malaysia which is on the left and
specifically johor which is the state um
that is most southernmost and it's hard
to tell from this perspective but
singapore and malaysia are separated by
a small water body called the johor
strait and
connecting the two countries physically
is the johor causeway or more commonly
known as just the causeway
so a summary of this case uh can be
summed up in these couple of bullet
points so current water agreements
regulate the importation of raw water
from job or malaysia to singapore and
importation of treated water from
singapore to joe form so this map shows
a simple overview of the johor river
basin and you can see the prominent
johor river and the lingu reservoir and
then the dotted line represents the
series of pipes that cross the joe horse
street
um there's also complex river networks
that offshoot from the main river
as well as you can see the johor river
barrage which is something i'll talk
about a little bit more that was a joint
project to improve the water supply
there have been four main agreements
signed between the two
parties and the last agreements will
expire in 2061 that's a number that or
like a year that's going to come up a
lot
and despite ongoing negotiations since
1990 they've still failed to reach
another agreement
classified as water stressed and relies
on water from johor to currently meet 40
percent of its water demand so extremely
significant and they're unable to meet
their demand
without this imported water
and a blossoming issue is the fact that
jopor has increasing issues with meeting
its own water demand due to a
combination of increased pollution as
well as droughts
so to talk about malaysian water
resources malaysia is fortunate to have
very abundant water resources despite
being so close to singapore it has quite
a different landscape it's covered in
rainforests and experiences heavy
rainfall almost all year
some malaysian states do suffer from
chronic water shortages while others are
experiencing surpluses so how is that
possible
um before 1992 state governments had
almost complete control over surface
water resources
so
i guess there's
you can
so as a result
there's been a lot of issues of water
management between the state government
and the federal government which has
tried to become more involved as
more issues arise kind of across the
states that are common and related to
water resources
climate change and droughts put malaysia
at an increasing risk of becoming water
stressed in the next 50 years according
to research done by institutions such as
the world resources institute i use
their like water risk atlas a lot to
help shape like
my projections for this case and i think
it's really important to note that um
currently malaysia and specifically
johor has a lot of water and could
manage it more efficiently to meet its
needs but it's possible even managed
efficiently they won't be able to do so
in the future
and i think kind of the biggest point
here is that malaysia does not manage
its water resources effectively
currently which is a big reason driving
why they're unable to meet their water
demand
the this includes insufficient
infrastructure to collect rainfall
extreme water pollution due to
unregulated practices of mining logging
land development and sewage disposal
they have almost no water conservation
efforts they're hesitant to invest in
alternative water resources so things
like desalination or wastewater reuse
and
still despite all of these things they
have agreements in place to export water
to both singapore and melaka
um so the image here on the upper right
is
from part of a river in johor and it was
taken many years ago so it's actually
much harder to find natural river or
like water resources that don't more
resemble that bottom image
where there's just a lot of pollution
buildup and very poor water quality
singapore water resources is quite the
different story um
the main issue that singapore faces is
that it doesn't have enough natural
water supply to support their growing
population and economy
and since 1965 when singapore and
malaysia separated from their brief
union quite acrimoniously singapore has
made a very extreme effort to implement
a three-pronged strategy to decrease
their water vulnerability and water
dependence especially from malaysia by
2061 when their current agreements are
going to expire
so this three-pronged approach first
focused on optimizing their domestic
water supply by building dams and
reservoirs
they have built a total of 11 reservoirs
in addition to three that existed before
1965.
these reservoirs cover about half of
singapore's total land area you can see
in this image in the upper right
kind of a glimpse of where the
reservoirs are it's hard to tell but
there's small colorful dots
this is from 2014 but these are all the
projects that are started or finished
having to do with water catchment
um so actually after 1986 there is
almost no opportunities to increase
their water catchment
just due to restrictions in land area
so they then turn to the second two
prongs of their strategy which includes
securing alternative water supplies
through sea water desalination
wastewater reuse which they're one of
the most advanced systems in the world
they have a reclaimed water program
called new water
and negotiating a new agreement with
indonesia for imported water i'm really
not going to focus on that third one
because they haven't reached an
agreement yet
but the other two are part of their um
are have currently already started to be
implemented and hope to increase in the
future um and the final prong of their
approach is to improve water
conservation so they also went at this
quite aggressively they added
regulations as well as monetary
incentives for individuals as well as
businesses they've made investments in
new water conservation technology as
well as improving existing
infrastructure to decrease the amount of
water lost to leaks
and then they also launched a large
budget education campaign
so it was very successful already
singapore is experiencing a 0.2 percent
decrease in water consumption per year
despite continued population and
economic growth so very impressive most
parts of the world especially with
developing economies are increasing
water consumption per capita so
um
pretty interesting and then here
this is a slightly outdated infographic
published by singapore's public
utilities board also known as pub which
shows singapore's plan for decreasing
their reliance on imported water and
increasing their reliance on reclaimed
water from wastewater which is the new
water campaign which currently supplies
30 percent of their water demand but
they have ambitious plans to be relying
on it for about up to 55 by
2060 and then seawater desalination is
currently 10 of their water demand but
they hope to be up to 30 percent by
2060. so again they're really um
i think
the domestic water supply is about 20
and won't really change so they're
hoping that if they are successful in
this three-pronged approach they
wouldn't be reliant on malaysia but as i
mentioned at the beginning
um currently they're still 40 reliant on
water from malaysia and it seems pretty
unlikely that they'll be a hundred
percent independent um in just like 40
years
so next i want to talk about the key
stakeholders in the water negotiations
so
i'm not very familiar with the
governmental structure of singapore and
malaysia so based on my research about
the water conflict i'm going to show you
the stakeholders that stood out
in my paper i mentioned more about how
media had a unique role in the water
conflict basically news about water
negotiations and agreements were widely
covered in the local newspapers in both
singapore and malaysia
where the newspapers were not only
publishing factual news coverage there
is also like increasingly negative
partisan editorials and letters that
were shared
so this combined with the lack of
transparency from both governments went
so far as
like one point the governments were just
communicating with each other through
the newspapers so like one government
official in singapore read a malaysian
newspaper
with a public statement from a malaysian
official that had not been talked about
officially behind closed doors so then
they had to
release a different statement to their
local newspapers and on and on um so it
is quite complex and something that i
didn't want to muddle this idea but it
meant that there's a lot of stakeholders
with opinions about the negotiations
that are not at the table so people or
groups like
representing ecology
as well as competing minority political
groups in both
territories
so here um we're going to talk about the
malaysian key stakeholders which are
stakeholders from both the federal and
state governments so much of malaysia's
water management happens at the state
level however malaysia's political
relationship with singapore inherently
involves federal stakeholders so that
would be people like the prime ministers
um later i'll mention that a change in
malaysian leadership will improve
negotiations so that's due to prime
minister mahathir
mohamad whose picture is i placed on the
right
because he was a driving force
preventing further water agreements from
being reached during his
like
position as prime minister and
unfortunately for water diplomacy he
governed two times separately and
basically
has a very
primary focus on water pricing and
wanting to increase water prices for
singapore and um
unfortunately like a focus on
competitive pricing is just not
conducive to progress um
so anyway uh the national water council
and the national water resources council
were created in the 1990s to improve
water management specifically between
the state and federal levels
but i would say overall
malaysia's water management is still
relatively disorganized and ultimately
ineffective
and that's just a challenge that will
need to be addressed and then finally
the bacharach is a malaysian counterpart
of the pub which is the singapore public
utilities board that runs their water
management
so currently bacharach and pub have
monthly meetings to discuss water topics
quickly to go over the singaporean key
stakeholders as i've mentioned several
times now their management is led by the
pub which was founded in 1963 and is
part of the ministry of sustainability
and environment in singapore
publicly the singaporean prime ministers
and more recently
the minister of foreign affairs um
minister vivian has been quite involved
in the diplomatic relations with
malaysia and they're the ones who would
be responsible for signing any official
agreements between um malaysia and
singapore
so um in my paper i have like a pretty
in-depth description of the terms of all
four water agreements between singapore
and malaysia but for the sake of time
i'm going to highlight the main points
that you need to understand so starting
in 1927 singapore rented a plot of land
in johor at an annual rate and then can
use all the water found in and on the
land
in return johor would buy back specific
amounts of treated water from singapore
an interesting thing to note is that
this agreement allowed for increases in
land and treated water purchased and
traded
expecting that the water needs would
change and
they would probably want to increase
that so they specifically wrote that in
the 1961 and 1962 agreements replaced
the 1927 agreement they expanded the
amount of resources that would be
traded between the two they defined a
certain rate at which the prices um like
the water would be bought so
um in this agreement
singapore would buy um water raw water
from johor at 37 per 1000 gallons while
malaysia would buy treated water for 50
cent per 1000 gallons so i mentioned
that because the agreements both include
um price like a joint price review every
25 years
unfortunately none of the times that
they've met so i think the last one was
in 1986 and 1987
they weren't able to reach any update
even though an update was necessary it's
like both sides kept asking for a little
bit too much so as a result they got no
agreement um so
to this day the water is still being
sold for three sun per thousand gallons
and 50 cents so that that will really
come back later when i talk about what
needs to be done
and finally the 1990 agreement was an
extension of the 1962 agreement it
authorized a new construction of another
dam
singapore has made a lot of
infrastructure investments in johor to
increase their water supply but also
benefits the local johor community and
completely at the singaporean expense
i guess to sum up the
one agreement expired in 2011 and then
there's two that are still active
but again they were not able to renew
the one that expired in 2011 so as a
result singapore had to decrease the
amount of water they imported from
malaysia
a couple of supplemental things that you
might care about is the 1965 separation
agreement which is also known as the
independence of singapore agreement
and it included a clause ensuring that
malaysia would abide by the terms of the
water agreements already signed to
ensure singapore's water security and
this was filed with the united nations
the 1998 and through 2003 water pricing
negotiations
were a time when malaysia and singapore
were trying to negotiate another
agreement that would last for 100 years
to extend this deadline of 2061.
malaysia was motivated because they
needed finances from singapore to back
their currency because there was a
financial crisis um and singapore just
wanted to secure water resources um for
an extended period of time um once
malaysia no longer needed the finances
because they got it from somewhere else
the negotiations were reduced to debates
about the water pricing packaging the
water policies with other partisan
issues
and um just got out of control
in these negotiations malaysia tried to
increase the price of raw water from
three cent per 1000 gallons to 45
then 60 cent and finally 625 per
thousand gallons in 2002 and um
as you might expect no agreement was
made
finally i highlight the johor river
barrage
project which was a three-year project
funded by singapore
and
addressed the saltwater intrusion to the
johor river basin
so that's
an example of
both johor and singapore
were suffering from a reduced quality of
water in the river basin so singapore
agreed to fund a project that would
improve these and ensure a longer-term
water
resource
so now um
i would love to talk about the water
diplomacy framework and how this fits in
so the singapore malaysia water conflict
is unique because there's only two
parties involved sharing water resources
that are not physically common the water
networks are defined through several
water agreements where water is being
traded rather than shared however johor
and singapore still mutually benefit
from the terms of the existing
agreements and they have acknowledged
that publicly
the water diplomacy framework
acknowledges the complexity of managing
competition feedback and interconnection
between the natural and societal domains
in the context of the political domain
so that is absolutely true in this
circumstance there were ongoing societal
tensions between singaporean and
malaysian communities at every level
over a lot of issues not just water
and so um
and then johor has been experiencing
increasing water problems in the natural
domain related to water quantity as well
as quality which threatens both
stakeholders
and finally because the media was so
involved in
covering the water negotiations the
group of stakeholders with opinions is
actually much larger than the officials
that are involved in the signing of the
agreements and as a result um there's
like kind of a negative error around the
um like agreements and signing a new
agreement
so something that i recognized
immediately is that um
there would need to be
trust built between the stakeholders so
the first issue that needs to be
addressed is how to build this trust and
enhance cooperation between the
different stakeholders
mainly state government officials and
before negotiations can make progress
stakeholders from both sides will need
to recognize and accept the value of
being cooperative rather than
competitive which is something we talked
a lot about in this class so one of the
stickiest points in the current
negotiations is the water pricing for
the raw water bought by singapore and
the treated water bought by johor
however
both um
like singapore and johor have increasing
concerns about their water security so
i think it'd be really beneficial to
shift the conversations away from
competitive water pricing that's
motivated by self-interest and start by
discussing cooperative strategies for
making sure that both parties will have
enough water of the right quality
because the opportunities for mutual
gains would then be more prioritized
which is what obviously
they both need
so
um i guess i will note that there are
ongoing negotiations and conversations
and meetings between singapore and
malaysian officials so um i think things
that have been highlighted is they have
an annual leaders retreat which is
literally just a retreat for their
leaders to meet um joint
committee meetings that happen on
monthly um and yearly basis the
ministers of both countries visit the
other country to improve relations
and then they've recently created the
malaysia singapore joint committee on
the environment um which is also like
basically for this kind of um
to increase the relations in these
topics so there's starting to be
progress but it's really
not being reflected in any um
legislative progress um in my opinion
this is something that i thought was
interesting to point out so
um most partisan
media articles from both uh sides
reflect slightly different versions of
the same story so malaysian media
articles would say that the current
agreements only benefit singaporean
stakeholders johor is experiencing
increasing incidence of water scarcity
and singapore just keeps taking the
amount that it's always agreed upon
despite the circumstances changing
the water pricing has not been updated
and as a result singapore is getting
this raw water at way below the price
that they should be buying it up
and then conservative singaporean media
outlets would frame the issue quite
differently but it's ultimately the same
story where singapore has been actively
trying to reduce its reliance on water
from johor while continuously granting
requests from johor for more treated
water than agreed upon in the agreements
at the same discounted rates
this is just to maintain goodwill
between the two parties
and singapore has prioritized enhancing
their water security by extending the
water agreements however
if johor wants to increase the price of
raw water singapore would have to
increase the price of treated water
so
this slide is basically
um to go over how
both sides if you look at it objectively
could be gaining from this relationship
um i chose this image this is a
screenshot from the aqueduct water risk
atlas tool that i mentioned before
this is their projection for water risk
in singapore and johor in 2040 if things
continue quote business as usual so as
you can tell singapore is classified as
extremely high risk and johor is medium
to high risk so for reference currently
if you click to baseline both are
classified as low risk so
this is something where their water risk
characteristics are increasing due to
changes in climate change drought
and pollution
so
um
currently singapore and johor rely on
each other to meet their water demands
they both care about the decreasing
water quality in malaysia since it
jeopardizes both water security of
singapore and malaysia
i recognize that singapore has much more
and better experience in launching water
conservation campaigns as well as
investing in alternative water supplies
they have one of the most advanced
systems in the world for desalination
and water reuse
as well as like very strict water
quality
tactics because they don't want to waste
their own water so i think that's one
opportunity where both nations could
benefit if singapore could
give some of their experience and help
improve the situation in malaysia
secondly both parties are unsure of the
long-term effects of climate change and
drought on their water security
so they both want to be resilient and
prepared to adapt to changing water
circumstances
the water prices for both the raw water
and the treated water are absolutely
outdated and should be updated um
however that should not be like the only
thing included in the conversation
because that
is currently only representing
self-interest
singapore benefits from johor's water
supply to support its like economic
growth it needs the water
and while they say that they will be
independent by 2061 that has not been
proven and i think furthermore an
ongoing water relationship for singapore
is convenient because singapore has
already made long-term infrastructure
investments and already have good
existing relationships with the water
representatives there so rather than
trying to find a different importing
place to get water from it makes sense
that singapore want to stick with
malaysia
and finally malaysia would benefit
because they need the increased supply
of treated water and they need
assistance stimulating progress
in increasing their supply long term
since they have no progress in water
treatment development water conservation
development or water pollution
regulation
so finally um a couple other ways that
the um water diplomacy framework could
be utilized include um utilizing an
impartial moderator so it was really
successful when they lodged um the
document with the un after they split
politically to ensure that malaysia
would not re-nudge on their agreement
and i'm really confused why they haven't
done that since it seems like
incorporating some more impartial
stakeholders could really help promote
progress
and secondly i i think it'd be
interesting if they would
start conversations about signing a new
agreement unrelated to the water supply
but kind of more toward a joint
agreement
trying to become more resilient in the
face of climate change this part of the
world is extremely vulnerable and um if
singapore malaysia and some of these
other south south eastern asian
countries and states join together um in
their efforts to develop new technology
and get better information it would
really benefit
them all
so yeah these are the key takeaways
but i think just for the sake of time um
it's pretty clear that singapore and
malaysia
can't already recognize that their
agreements are mutually beneficial
however
they've not been able to
um reach further agreements which is
threatening both the water security of
both and
ultimately
preventing progress and security
[Music]
yeah
thank you flora for the nice
presentation it's really wonderful um
so
yeah is there any feedback for flora
s9 or casino
well well done for your wonderful
presentation uh as this topic was new
for you uh you have done a very great
job uh just first of all let me give you
a small comment um
as you mentioned uh
and a prospect about desalination uh my
view would be that desalination is
expensive and its production is energy
intensive and
and it involves carbon emissions in the
long run malaysia might not be able to
operate and
maintain it as well
as as you mentioned in the case study
that malaysia has had some availability
of water of fresh water and receives
ample rainfall it would be better for
singapore to cooperate and invest in
water infrastructure uh enhancing
malaysia's storage capacity which in
turn would ensure long-term water
security for singapore uh the malaysia
could in turn offer increased water
quantity to singapore this could be a
practical mutual gains approach uh in
respect to the water diplomacy framework
um
and and secondly uh the question would
be that what is the public sentiment in
malaysia given their own water scarcity
situation you mentioned that some states
receive are water scars
and and you mentioned that that as per
the treaty
water flows uh freely to singapore uh
but some states within malaysia face
water scarcity so what is the public
sentiment within malaysia about that
i can respond to that um
yeah so definitely the public response
is pretty negative um i think
uh
it's like negative in every regard it's
like uh we want to sell the water to
singapore but they need to pay us way
more like we want we want to sell it to
them but they're not paying enough and
then it's also like
why are they taking our water when we
don't have enough water like that's not
that's not fair either so i think um
part of that is unavoidable just because
um yes singapore also needs the water
and it's confusing um but i i think the
public sentiment uh is tainted by
political sentiment that's just like
malaysians don't like singaporean as
like a like stereotype um but then like
further aggravated by this
increased water scarcity caused by these
droughts and lack of rain capture
so yeah definitely is negative and
not very controlled like the information
shared in malaysia is not the same
information shared in singapore media is
extremely regulated in both countries
and is highly partisan so as a result
it's really hard to change public
opinion but from what i understand the
public doesn't have much control over
what happens
so
and just one more thing
um
uh you know as you mentioned that the
treaty expires in 2061 and it's it is
still four decades until the existing
treaties is going to expire
and some clarity is required why
negotiations uh um have
are needed to extend
uh uh
like like why negotiations have already
started as of now because it is still
four decades remaining uh or or the two
countries are eyeing to formalize a new
treaty before 2061
in order to cater for existing water
scarcity and water quality issues
yeah so basically from their point of
view 40 years is not long at all
um they
in 2000 in the early 2000s they were
trying to negotiate a treaty that would
last for 100 years so extend it from
2061 to more like 3 000 one sounds so
weird to say
um but
yeah they were unable to reach one but
basically
especially for singapore since this is
more of an issue of water security in
the next 40 years if um in 2061 there
they don't they aren't able to import
water from malaysia anymore and they
have not succeeded in increasing their
water reuse and water desalination um
basically singapore will no longer be
able to supply water to
run its
like municipal and industrial water
supply so that uh i guess is the threat
of um water security and like some
parties would even say like
what would they like um would they try
to like fight malaysia um some kind of
water war most people say no but that's
like basically why it's so urgent why
they don't want to wait until 10 years
before because already negotiations have
been going on for
30 years and they haven't reached any
agreement
thank you
wonderful presentation florida every
time i have a question my mind your next
slide answer my question it was very
good
uh
do you think that's uh indonesia could
be considered a bachelor for singapore
well it seems like
they'll run into the same issues that
they're running into malay with malaysia
but having a little bit less bad blood
um and it's extremely less convenient
since um like already singapore has
invested so much in the malaysian water
resources that if they were going to do
the same thing in indonesia it would be
like starting from scratch and also
probably ruin their relationship with
malaysia like decrease their chances of
renewing the water agreements
so i think in that regard it's been
quite hard also the main thing holding
up any negotiations is that indonesia
has had a lot of political turmoil
internally so just the lack of
governance has prevented
real conversations from happening
yeah florida
if you if you know more about this um
innovation
can you talk about the four taps and the
new water
solutions
yeah so singapore has one of the like
most developed i mean larry and anamesh
can stop me if i'm just saying wrong
things but um like a very advanced water
um recycling program so new water is
what they're calling it um
i have a manager from my internship that
lives in singapore and she always laughs
at me when she says like in your country
you call like water reclaimed water like
toilet to tap and she's like that sounds
gross like no wonder no one likes it um
she's like you know in singapore we call
it new water like everyone wants new
water new water sounds great and like
cool and innovative she's like toilet to
tap like
that's that's bad advertising
um so yeah basically they've really
worked on increasing their reclaimed
water supply they have very advanced
technology to do water reuse which is a
technology that's not utilized very much
in the us there's not as much technology
development in the u.s
because of this hesitancy from the
public and industry to
adopt it but that is like what they're
mainly relying on where instead of
getting rid of waste water you'd be able
to recycle it one or two times to use it
again which obviously makes sense and
then
seawater desalination is their other big
technology push for their four taps um
other than the rainfall capture since
that is basically
um just like exhausted they don't have
any more land to expand into so um yeah
i think
uh houston like raised a good point
desalination is expensive it
currently relies on carbon fuel
and will wear out
potentially if it's not maintained
properly so
um yeah i think that's interesting i
haven't really read any articles right
now singapore is just really in the push
to increase
the amount of water that they are
obtaining from non-malaysian sources
thank you very much for congratulations
again
thanks
i just want to annotate the question of
desal uh a little bit
um desalination uh now is completely
solar powered
and um
the israelis have created
very advanced
desalination technologies again for
their own uses
israel is going to be almost 85 percent
decel uh in the next decade even though
they have water um
they have aquifers but they're not going
to hold out forever
and um
israel has developed
new technologies for um
separating the brine from the
fresh water um
kuwait
is 95
desal
everything in the country 95 of the
water is from d south um so
yes it was true
that desal was mostly fossil fuel driven
it isn't
no one planning a future
gsal facility of large scale would think
in unless there were
an oil
generating country and had so much extra
oil they didn't know what else to do but
that isn't the case with singapore um
i i personally think that singapore will
have no problem
through recycling
people have to understand that malaysia
and singapore think of themselves as
developed countries
they do not think of themselves as
developing them they have the most
advanced technology they have the most
advanced
universities um singapore
has uh
used advanced technology on just about
everything
and because it is a small island nation
it has the limitations as or nicely
pointed out
of scale in terms of land
but it's going to be able to claim
uh
existing space at its edges
and expand development
on
the water
and my sense is that it's not
crazy to think that singapore through
desal because it's got all of this area
on the ocean
and water recycling which is the most
advanced in the world for municipal
systems
and a space that can't grow
in terms of large additional population
and it can't increase density because
it's already as high as manhattan
so my sense is that um they've made some
smart choices and i think they will take
advantage of water from malaysia when
they need it as they need it
um
the other thing that has to uh be noted
uh is that
johor is a state
in malaysia
but
malaysia has two parts
it's the the peninsula part that you
talked about
is is in one place
and the other two states
it's like hawaii and alaska for
americans the other two states are on
top of
borneo
they're
on top of another country as far away as
hawaii is from san francisco
does it and those two states are amongst
the most important income generating
states because that's where all the
natural resources are
and um
so
the water policy in malaysia is doesn't
really
focus on
the the two states that are separate
because there's very few people there
and
i mean comparatively and there's plenty
of water so the water issues are in the
peninsula
uh malaysia and
um my sense is that
there's plenty of water um i'm a little
less
negative i think flora than you are
about their uh pollution improvements
over the last decade
they took
in all of their cities where the rivers
run through the city
they got the idea from san antonio
instead of covering over the river and
just dumping everything in it
they uncovered the river
and they made it a attraction of the
city which meant they had to do the
pollution cleanup
and the level of pollution cleanup i
mean i've been working in malaysia for a
decade and even from year one to year
seven
the difference
in pollution levels in rivers is really
dramatic
and the coordination which i understand
you know when you look and do research
on this
the coordination between the federal
level and the state levels is
dramatically enhanced
in the last five years
now they had this crazy change of
governments
and now they're back to a
normal kind of government that has
qualified people in senior positions
there was a period a few years ago where
the transition happened where the people
running stuff were political appointees
with zero professional background
and capabilities but now things are back
in order so i i think there's a chance
of the negotiations
since a friend of mine is the head of
the commission and will be doing the
negotiations i i think there's a chance
that they will
find all of these mutual
benefits that you point out
how i mean johor
it has all these facilities being built
by singapore the national government is
saving the money and johor is saving the
money and
if singapore is willing to build all
these facilities
and
if singapore continues to increase its
own water resources it doesn't it won't
be so scary about its long-term need for
all of george
water um
two other things that have happened
maybe since
the published the material you were
looking at was published
one is that the chinese developer
has built a new city
floating
in the straits of johor right between
johor
malaysia and singapore
and it's um it's it's malaysian so
singapore is quite distressed
about it especially because and this is
the other thing you had it on the slide
but you need to explain it
malaysia is a democracy
but
it also is a monarchy
and so you know we're used to thinking
about how the british government
operates
well the sultans there are six sultans
six sulpinates within malaysia and each
year one of them is the sultan of
sultans and the sultanate is in
is in the constitution
and has a variety of things that it
controls
and the sultan
of johor is a
is a player in the conversation even
though it's country to country
because the sultan has real say within
which what what malaysia does
malaysia is a muslim country
even though
chinese and indian populations are
growing
it's basically a muslim country and all
of the original settlers came from
indonesia
and so there are implicit connections to
indonesia but indonesia is a long way
away how are you going to get water
i'm not going to have a pipe
from indonesia to johor that's nuts
so my sense is that that you're exactly
on target that they need to
to do something about these negotiations
quickly
and there are plenty of joint gains to
be had
but the negotiation will include johor
even though it's a state
i think they ought to encourage the
involvement of malacca which is another
state
which isn't
uh um assaulting it in the same way
and
would benefit by part of being part of
the deal
and
i think we we should expect that
solar powered
desal
will be
very important in producing maybe
40 or 50 percent of everything
that
uh
that they need into the future
and that recycling
and this huge construction of all of
these
uh uh reservoirs it's amazing a tiny
little island
built 11 big reservoirs to capture rain
water because they saw this problem
coming so they
they're not in terrible shape malaysia's
not in terrible shape there are
advantages to be had yes the pricing is
going to have to change
but there's so much shared
interest in other things
that um the last thing i would expect is
a water war i mean that they don't have
an army
so that would make a difference
uh
i mean malaysia does but my sense is
that these two
nations and johor
will um be able to figure this out but
you you do a beautiful job of describing
the history
of identifying
why
these negotiations are important
um the older negotiations were in a
different time
before
um you have such powerful economic
countries
these were developing countries now they
are developed
nations with lots of money
and
they they should be able to deal with
each other so i think your emphasis is
just right that the only two things i
would point out which i think the threat
of doing something with indonesia is
nuts
uh
just because of distance
and because indonesia has its own
problems
to worry about
um and i think so i think
and i think that this this floating city
forest city
that's what they called it forest
city
seven hundred thousand people on floor
four floating platforms in in wetland in
an internationally protected wetland
it's
a disaster and so that's what led to the
new joint effort
on environment and sustainability which
is malaysia never should have allowed it
to happen but the national government
defers on land use issues to the
state
and the sultan of johor is one of the
major investors
in this ridiculous gigantic new city
and he was in it for the money and it
was his land and because it was he owned
this spec of island
he didn't need to get any permissions to
build and the chinese developer was
happy to fill
and so they filled everything and it
created it killed all the fishing
industry up and down
the strait
and every oh this is a mistake and they
had to dig it out and they had to re-go
back and they did this through court
action because singapore brought suit
against malaysia and the malaysian
government sheepishly said well
it was the state we didn't we didn't
know what they were doing
and this project is
the largest
um
planned community by a chinese developer
outside of china
and it's a gated community for chinese
but it's going to use all the water and
all the services and everything else
from johor
i mean there's so many things around it
which is
but it it's created the need for
malaysia national government and
singapore national government to work
together
on the alleging its climate change it's
on sustainable development and the
protection of wetlands and the
protection of other resources
sorry to go on it's just i i think
you did a beautiful job
um i
delighted you chose the subject and
we'll be able to put this
in the collection because it's an
important example of nations
where states within nations really are
players
so this nation the nation treaty thing
it the agreement isn't going to happen
without
johorean involvement
and
it involves all kinds of technology
anyway i think they did a great job for
thanks so much
yeah so thanks for fluoride it was a
wonderful presentation and um i think in
terms of improvement um
in terms of exploration you did
excellent job as i read your
draft paper and i already
made comments i already sent to you but
uh in the presentation you um
incorporated the
water diplomacy framework very well but
in the paper it was not uh so maybe you
will work on that and um
so maybe for the um what are the
implementing water diplomacy framework
if you just focus on the
um conflict uh in in my view this uh
conflict now they stuck is that the
malaysia is demanding um
price increasing
and um
and uh singapore is is not willing to
provide that much um amount for for the
raw water so in that point how you can
um
uh yeah so how this stock can be um
this positional things can be
improved by this joint finding things
the the issue that you already mentioned
if you just um describe in a way that
can provide a
systematic uh explanation of the things
i think that then the paper could be uh
fantastic it's already nice but it can
be further improved in that in that part
so yeah do you think flora your tone
about the relationship
between these two countries and its
historical
um
roots is very very true and very very
important
and one of the reasons is that this
really simple
water money
recycled water or treaty isn't getting
fixed is
singapore doesn't want to admit any need
for anything from malaysia
it's just it goes back to when they
pulled apart and singapore felt it
developed itself as a as a developed
nation uh and it you know
malaysia took so much longer and didn't
know how to do what they did and they
don't want to be beholden
i mean i i have the advantage of talking
with the person who's doing the
negotiations from malaysia who's a
scientist
and um he thinks the whole thing is
ridiculous
and he just doesn't understand well what
what what do you want what's that the
price come on
let's ask some independent folks what
the value of the water is in the
recycled water and you've got a huge
amount of money it's not about the money
um and i think by involving more of the
states it would be easier for singapore
to say well we did this because we're
helping those states
because they just
can't swallow the idea
of
doing anything for or
needing malaysia and i think you
captured that
that tone very appropriately in your in
your paper from the history
i think that's one of the interesting
parts of reading so many very partisan
like articles it's like
very clear like it makes it even more
clear like
where the gaps and communication and
like pride and
things like that play in because it's
just so obvious like as somewhat
impartial you feel like the parent like
watching your kids bicker you're like
you can both like have water like you
don't need to like
just say the other person's ugly like
you can just take the water and then we
call it a day so yeah it was very
interesting there is not much literature
but there's a lot of coverage there's a
lot of events yeah well people have been
discouraged scholars have been
discouraged from writing about it quite
explicitly at
technology malaysia that i work with
they've been told don't don't do it it's
you
you're killing your career if you
write anything scholarly about this
because this isn't really a scholarly
issue
and nobody that doesn't come bite me
later yeah
so um
but i mean for for us studying what a
diplomacy to understand
that the root issue is this historical
not just lack of trust but really
almost hatred
of two parties that were part of the
same country
i mean
it's difficult and i think there's also
partly this is about
um the fact that the muslim majority
in malaysia is
in some ways
losing control
uh i mean it still gets who it wants
elected but
and is still 51 muslim
and
chinese though are
really controlling
industry in malaysia they're controlling
wealth in malaysia
whereas the um
uh muslim majority bare majority is
controlling government
in malaysia and certain
a few industries
and uh it's
singapore
not interested
in uh acknowledging the power
of a malaysian partner
who's muslim
they're much more focused on chinese and
the muslim majority in malaysia
thinks that the chinese minority is
using its connections to singapore to
build more of its strength and power in
malaysia and wants to take over the
government which has always been the
domain of the muslim majority
so
all of these
pieces and parts these are part of water
diplomacy and i think your your case is
important because it brings out these
are not just
you know about natural resource
management
or uh territory
this is about these lack of trust in
this difficult relationship
between the two countries which you do a
really nice job of raising